so President Joe Biden's life expectancy
is a topic of concern as voters consider
his potential second term at 80 years
old Biden's statistical possibilities of
living to finish this term is uncertain
as you'd expect the rise the risk of
dying increases as we ate says Katia uh
irvaisi of a nerd wallet according to
larvasi an 80 year old the male Biden
has a 33 31 chance of dying in the next
33 percent chance 31 chance of dying in
the next five years and a 64.27 chance
of dying within the next 10 years
however Biden's health challenges and
the stress of being president raises
questions about his ability to compete
complete a second term if Biden were to
win a re-election but not complete his
term vice president Kamala Harris will
become the first female president so
it's age an issue with you right now do
you think Dems are starting to realize
it age with Joe Biden yes or yeah I mean
yes but I I have a contrarian view here
where I don't think candidates really
matter nearly as much as they used to as
long as the Democrats are the only ones
that are investing in meaningful
election infrastructure this is
something we're talking a lot about at
Turning Point action at our big action
conference by the way if you're if
you're in Florida come this weekend
tpaction.com just had to plug that uh
and by the way value Tim's gonna have a
booth there yeah
tpaction.com but what does election
infrastructure it's data voter
registration election Integrity early
voting ballot chasing I say this
kiddingly but not really they could run
Jimmy Carter from hospice and win
because they can micro Target their
voters run a bunch of ads what a point
and John fetterman is is in evidence of
this so I'm not as interested in the
horse race of the who I'm interested in
the how and the how is the boring but
necessary clipboard and Tennis Shoes
type of Grassroots work that quite
honestly we used to make fun of Barack
Obama for we call them a Chicago
Community political organizer but that's
what they've now built and so for just
one example the game has totally changed
because of covet and our reaction to
coveted with mass mail and balloting
Georgia used to had to used to have 240
000 uh for 247 000 mail-in ballots in
2018 you can look up the number I
believe Georgia had about like 2.4
million people vote by mail in the
midterms in 2022 that's a 10-fold
increase
um and so but that the whole game has
changed then so it went from a Democrat
plus eight State uh Republic state to
now a Democrat plus one state
um yeah you could look at the actual
final numbers there so I don't know like
the Joe Biden thing he can't make
coherent sentences can't do all that I
don't know I don't know how much it
matters I think right now until we as
Republicans achieve parity with the
Democrats with the boring stuff of
elections candidates are not going to
matter for quite some time got it I
think you had something to say about
yeah the whole question was Biden's life
expectancy right this is actually
something I know a lot about this is
actually my business ideal in life
insurance and life insurance settlements
you take out a policy on him
it's probably it's probably too old to
take out a policy but he probably has a
policy but yes I'm very familiar with
how life insurance works and how Life
policies work because I buy them off of
old people understand what I just said I
buy life insurance policies off of old
people and I give them money so it is my
job to actually understand their life
expectancy morbidities literally it's
called it's called the mortality tables
and here's how this works so I actually
did the life expectancy of a couple
different scenarios for Biden's health I
ran it at standard health I ran it at
substandard health and I ran it at
uninsurable Health right if Biden is
considered standard Health right
he'd have 128 month life expectancy okay
standard Health that's 10 years
substandard table two table four right
you're talking 93 to 100 months okay if
he's completely uninsurable for his age
500 rating he'd have a 60 month life
expectancy that's five years so I
wouldn't put him that high you brought
up Jimmy Carter yeah okay Jimmy Carter
98 99 years old he's turning uh this
October right around your birthday by
the way yeah Warren Buffett 92. Charlie
Munger 99 George Soros 92. Henry
Kissinger 100 years old a couple famous
actors Harrison Ford 81 same age as
Biden what he was just in Indiana Jones
Al Pacino 83 DeNiro 79 Pesci 80 Clint
Eastwood 93 uh the list goes on and on
but here's the point we're talking about
Biden and his life expectancy at some
point once you reach 80 something years
old and you're in okay health and you
have money and you have the capabilities
to survive Biden's not going anywhere
and just like you made the reference
like you could run Jimmy Carter at 99
years old that's basically what's going
to happen with Biden yeah and if for
whatever reason he dies or doesn't run
Kamala Harris I think is actually more
beatable than Biden but Gavin Newsom is
a far harder candidate than Joe Biden
totally agree so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign